you expect me to talk I will never
betray planet Earth to you ever Caden
you and tentacle mouth do your worst for
criminy sakes him they're not gonna kill
you
your baby brother likes green beans
don't you you have the whole afternoon
to play but I need to see a clean plate
first okay Oh
make me proud Timmy I'm already so proud
of you
Templeton Templeton
they're just parents you should be
playing them like a kazoo easy for you
you liked green beans hmm high-fiber
with a smooth grassy flavor what's not
to hate
wait you could eat my beans sure could
mmm good beans so what's in it for me
what oh I'm happy to eat the beans but
for free was there a fire that burned
down the rules of business
this isn't a business we're a family I
don't live in sposta Templeton I live in
the free market it's all business
quid pro quo aka I do Z you dizzy I ate
your vegetables you owe me a favor
what favor we'll leave it open but know
this I will collect
hey there slugger
uh hello who was I talking to not a baby
because that'd be weird am i right
flight attendant Stephen well it's
Stephen I pronounced it earlier but I
know it's hard to remember things isn't
it like how you're supposed to be
buckled in your seat right now there we
go snug and safe and ready to soar are
we gonna sit like a good boy all the way
to bones up early yes sir and will there
be consequences if we don't yes sir
darn Skippy there will be have a great
play
we are back to work Templeton hello you
beautiful baby car bosses Brothers are
they always this friendly I can't have
my own brother ignorant to the art of
business it's embarrassing I make sure
the world loves babies more than puppies
more than kittens what's the threat what
cats don't play by rules fade up the
company's in your mashed potato hands
don't blow it just kidding of course you
will what's up
this meeting is making me uncomfortable
I'm gonna bag the tiger this is my job
on the line you made a choice to join a
family we can fix this what if you broke
up and landed on the cab just boom
starfish they say in fairness sir the
cat thought of it first
you can't kill what you can't see time
to go
mommy is a dirty liar
[Music]
you